Mauri Cooper's the Cowboys wide receiver
joining us on behalf of the Gatorade
beat the heat program educating athletes
across all sports about the importance
of hydration during the hot summer
months 15th year Gatorade beat the heat
names to raise awareness among athletes
parents and coaches how to properly
hydrate and we've certainly seen the the
bad parts of this to learn more about
Gatorades beat the heat program fans can
find heat safety tips on Gatorades
youtube channels we welcome in Amari
Cooper what was your second best sport
in high school my second best sport in
high school was definitely basketball
how good were you I was decent I was
decent
I was definitely better at football
though who plays in the NBA the way you
played basketball in high school pretty
good question I would say probably a mix
between Kyrie and Westbrook I was on a
flashy with the basketball I liked to
dribble water and I liked to score did
you play high school with Teddy
Bridgewater I did that was my high
school quarterback how good was he in
high school he was great he was the best
quarterback I've seen at that point did
he play basketball he played for a
little bit but uh he didn't played he
didn't finish the season as a basketball
player okay but did you did you know at
the time like that you guys were both
going to be going to play obviously
college but maybe a chance to play
professionally yeah I know at the time
of course teddy was really advanced he
was he was like the only 10th grader on
what he's a year older than me so
another 9th grade I was at a different
school but obviously I know everything
that was going on at the school I
transferred to because they were a
powerhouse and he was like the only 10th
grader on varsity he used to keep a
receiver at first and then he moved to
quarterback really
he was really a vanity eteri I mean that
is probably the best safety I've seen in
high school like the ball is anywhere in
this vicinity he's gonna he's gonna he's
gonna come up with the interception he's
a great athlete
how did Nick Saban close you uh well you
didn't really have to do much to close
me because I had my intention set I know
if I got a offer from Alabama that's
where I wanted to go
why then just because I liked what they
stood for I liked that they were winning
obviously it was important thing but um
just the way he coached the game he
approached the game I mean it was all
about hard work there it wasn't any
promises that like most recruiters would
do and tell you you would come in and
and be a starter he just gave me the
flat out truth that if I was good enough
to play as a freshman I would play and
that's all I really wanted to hear
because I really just wanted to compete
for a spot and so I think they did
everything the right way who do you
think is a funnier Nick Saban or Jason
Garrett oh well you know Co Saban is
really like that's a really underrated
shade of his like he's actually a really
funny guy like he has these jokes that
he intentionally tells and they're all
pretty much funny
Garrett doesn't really intentionally
tell tell jokes like saving does so it's
a hard question to answer because
Garrett is naturally funny as well yeah
but did you feel like you had to laugh
at Coach Saban because he's Coach Saban
I didn't know yeah I didn't feel like I
had to laugh at him but his jokes were
actually funny it's Jon Gruden funny Jon
Gruden is funny as well yeah he he's
naturally funny though I don't think he
never tries to be funny he's just funny
what do you miss about the Raiders what
do I miss about the Raiders
[Laughter]
I miss my teammates oh okay okay so but
you know the colors did you like those
uniform I mean you're playing for the
Cowboys you've been lucky you played for
you know these iconic brands here you're
pretty lucky so far yeah yeah very very
storied franchises they mean a lot to me
to have been a part of two great
organizations but who did you grow up
rooting for I'm from Miami so I grew up
a Dolphins fan did you did you hope to
play there uh I wouldn't say I hope to
play there I just hope to be a NFL
player it really didn't matter what team
I played was Dallas era was Miami any
good when you were growing up yeah they
always had a top five defense somewhere
I can remember when I was growing up it
would always go like ten and six nine
and seven but they didn't make the
playoffs very much because the decision
was just so hard
he's Amari Cooper the Cowboys wide
receiver if you want to explain a little
bit more about this beat the heat
program what would you tell our audience
or certainly the parents listening yes
so I'm just out here to help Gatorade
you know spread the message about the
importance of hydration and just to give
a couple of tips on a subject and this
is something because you played in hot
weather most of your life with miami
alabama and certainly dallas how is that
change though of what coaches I'll allow
you do or the you know the practice
policy when it comes to playing in the
heat yeah I think I think coaches are
just more aware I mean you know
obviously people have you know falling
out and things like that from
dehydration and it just being really hot
and so the coaches do a good job now of
making sure all the guys are hydrated
the water breaks are more often and more
intentional and you know that's a good
thing because it also helps with
performance when you're hydrated if you
want dak Prescott to know you're open
and you go back to the huddle what do
you say or is there a look
oh that's a good question oh I really
just try to you know what I try to do I
try to always be open like every place
every pathway so you always think you're
open right but I try to create like a
lot of separation so I'm tree kind of
create a semi route running and so I
want him to go and watch film and see
and like watch him play the 15 play to
say hey this guy he's open every place
so from then on he can know like
whatever whatever the past play is he
can expect me to be open in it and
that's how I go about that did you
recognize Jason Witten when he came in
with his new look who look like what his
hair okay that one do you guys do you
guys make fun of him do you give him
grief a little bit I'm not sure I think
I've heard some guys talk about his lack
on here but I don't know they've done it
to his face how do my Cowboys look this
year we look good we have a lot of
pieces in place a lot of young guys who
are you know putting in a lot of work
and just ready to go out there or
fighting and you know put on the best
possible season that we can have when's
dad getting paid that's above my pay
grade
when are you getting paid if Michael
Thomas is gonna get what he's getting
you got to be keeping an eye on that
contract right I I'm not watching
Michael Thomas his pocket I would if I
were you well you know what you might
not be but your agent is yeah probably I
think everything is gonna fall in place
underneath I think so too
hey thanks for joining us have fun with
this Gatorade people are great folks and
we appreciate your time amore yes they
are
thank you that's Amari Cooper Cowboys
wide receiver for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel two
39 on DirecTV stream for free on BR live
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]